we're talking more about life than we
are money but we always do around here
dr. John Delaney we call him dr. D
Ramsey personality newly minted joins us
and I probably for the next year of your
life will continue to introduce you and
say you're a PhD in counseling so that
people know who you are and you're able
to answer their questions about stress
about anxiety about fear about
boundaries about people that are being
unkind because they're afraid about
encouraging kindness and generosity
instead of spreading fear it's fair it's
valid to have concerns over the economy
right now it is valid to have concerns
over the coronavirus especially if you
are in one of the risk cat risk
categories but the overreaction to both
will bring over correction oversteering
when you think that you know almost
change lanes into another car the other
day and I almost oversteered hit the guy
on the other Lane back and almost went
into the wall there you go and more
people wreck from from the reaction than
they do just going ahead and reckon hmm
and and so the overreaction to either
can get you in trouble panic panic no
one makes good decisions when they're
panicked or drunk dr. art Laffer says so
here's an interesting for you one for
you John you're going to get to do a lot
of talk radio in the next several years
and a lot of situations where you're
gonna have a lot of opinions so I've
been doing this for thirty years and
there have been some people out there in
the marketplace that I have uh so
disagreed with and disagree with
everything but occasionally I find
myself aligned with them anyway and it's
uncomfortable that make sense absolutely
yeah and decide otherwise
you know wise man well a long time ago I
mean when back when she was a harvard
law professor Elizabeth Warren and I
were on the same side and Chuck Schumer
and I were on the same side of a
bankruptcy argument because the
Republicans were putting a bankruptcy
law through that went through that was
all about protecting the banks and not
the little man and it added teeth to
bankruptcy that was unnecessary I'm not
for bankruptcy but the so I found myself
aligned with these guys because they
were right you know and I had to admit
if you cold even though I even though
our
a feat of freezin our politics were and
the rest of our lives are not aligned in
any other way sure but I had to respect
the argument in the principal area and
there one of those guys is a guy named
Peter Schiff and Peter and I have been
notoriously at opposite ends of things
because I am just not a glass half-empty
guy I'm not a scarcity guy I am not
going to be during my lifetime you can
mark it down I will not be predicting
the end of the world there you I'm gonna
resist that good feed a lot of financial
people do it a lot of economists do it
there's something about a dark cloud
that follows some of them around and
Peter is continually predicting in the
world and you know if you predict it
long enough eventually you'll be right I
think that even if it's after your death
you know so but so I have picked on him
mercilessly in the past and I had said
anything about him bad about him in
about 15 years but we used to go at it
pretty hard but not directly but he
tweeted this today and I find myself
completely agreeing with him how can
anyone say this is not a financial
crisis especially when it's even an even
bigger financial crisis than one we had
in 2008 here's where I agree with him in
which that's a little bit hyperbole
right there a little bit of drama Peter
right you're just trying to build it up
again okay but here's where I agree with
him in an economy as highly leveraged as
ours every crisis becomes a financial
crisis I love it yeah the the the the
leverage the amount of debt in business
the amount of debt in personal lives
magnifies the volatility any little wave
becomes a tsunami that's exactly and
your personal life when you have death
when you don't have debt and you have a
pile of cash a wave is just like hey
that was fun right
or is it inconvenience at worst yeah I
just got wet look at that I think my
feet got wet and it's just it's a
different thing because but it rocks
your freaking world when you're
leveraged leverage magnifies your
stupidity there you go and it does in
the nation at the government level it
does in the personal level and in the
business level and to the extent you
have cash and don't have debt your life
is stabilized now that everyone's you
don't understand you
ffffff ever ever ever but all of a
sudden I even find myself aligned with
Peter Schiff so hats off to you Peter
nice tweet today in an economy as highly
leveraged as ours every crisis becomes a
financial crisis because people don't
have two minutes of money setback that's
right
given the amount of payments that they
have there I can afford these payments
means I'm always going to have my job
and means there's never gonna be a
ripple in the economy means I'm never
gonna have any personal problems
everything is gonna go perfect in my
life is what I can afford these payments
mean which is asinine the only thing you
can guarantee is that you're gonna have
challenges right now the only thing you
can guarantee is you can't guarantee
anything that's exactly right